and beyond for today is is
open so we're meeting to talk about
sudo boolean solving which is
what sat solving people say when they
talk about zero one integer linear
programming
and we are our speakers are done
liber and roman valon
and they're going to tell us about sat4j
which
is arguably the most
well-known and i think definitely the
most widely used
pseudo-boolean solver uh both in
academia and
industry and so they've promised us an
in-depth investigation of what's going
on
inside and i think our setup
for this week too is um but
the speakers will make this clear that i
think that there's a
intention to have it divided up into two
parts where you can leave halfway
but like so one hour regular seminar and
then a break
and then after that we go really deep
and even deeper deep dive
into technicalities so without further
ado daniel and roman please the floor is
yours
thanks for the introduction and uh
for inviting us so today we are going to
see uh what are the challenges
when we want to implement the stylist
algorithm in sudo boolean solvers
so first let me introduce the context of
sudo boolean solving
so in the earlier 2000s there has been
resolution in the architecture of set
solvers
with both the adoption of the cdcl
approach and the use of efficient
heuristics and data structures
which allows thanks to a kind of black
box approach
to make sat servers work on a wide range
of application problems without having
to
fine-tune too much the solver to
efficiently solve the problems
and we with this with this revolution we
got
two order of magnitude speed up on some
benchmarks compared to previous
generation of solvers
and now modern that soldiers can now
deal
with problems containing billions of
variables and clauses
so here is a brief overview of the cdcl
architecture implemented in solvers and
here we are
mostly going to focus on the proof
system used by the solver
and more precisely in the conflict
analysis
implemented in uh in set solvers
and in these solvers we have um
though so the cdc algorithm needs some
invariants
to to work and these invariants in set
solvers are that
are the fact that constraint propagates
only once so basically we have clauses
and once
every little but one our first c5 will
propagate
one literal and those constraints have a
single accession level
which is the one where all literals but
one are falsified
and with when uh close
as always propagates one literal
we say that it is a reason and sometimes
we have
conflicts when all literals are
falsified and during the conflict
analysis we
combine reason and conflicts and we know
in set solver that combining a reason
and a conflict
will always produce a conflict
and finally to detect the assertion so
basically when we
learn a new constraint we have a
syntactical criterion
to detect at which level we should
backjab
and we will see that all these
invariants will be broken
when we consider them in pseudo-boolean
solvers
and here the pseudo boolean solver we
will consider is set for j
so an open source library for set
solving
in written in java and developed since
2004
which supports suitable and solving and
max set solving
it has native suitability and support
and implements various
proof system to reason with the
suitability and constraints
and the solver is available at sat4j.org
so now let us define what are sudobuyan
constructs
so and first i want i would like to
motivate the use of pseudobullion
constraints
by the fact that modern set solvers are
very efficient in practice as i said
before
but some instances are completely out of
reach for sat solvers
and especially because of the weakness
of the resolution proof system
that is used during conflict analysis
and this is particularly true for
instances
that requires ability to count such as
speed general principle formulae
we state that you cannot put n pigeons
into n minus one holes
and the year wouldn't set solvers
perform fully
if we have more than 20 pigeons
but suitable and solder based on cottage
planes
may solve such instances in linear time
so let us see how we can represent such
problem with pseudobullion constraints
and a pseudo boolean constraint in
general is a constraint of this form
which is a weighted sum of free table
where all coefficients are integers
literals are li are literals
which means that we have a boolean
variable
or its negation within fact that the
negation of a variable
is equal to one minus this variable
in the model general way we have any
relational operator here
among these five operators here and the
degree of the constraint which is the
right hand side of the constraint here
is also an integer
so for example we have here a pseudo
boolean constraint
here a b c and d are literals
and we have various kinds of
coefficients
and without loss of generality we are
going to consider conjunctions of
normalized pb constraints
which are of this form so here all
coefficients
are non-negative integers and the degree
is also a non-negative integer
and the relational operator is always
equal is always at least here
so this is without loss of generality in
the sense that any
pseudo boolean constraint as i defined
before can be represented
in this form so for example if we get
the constraint represented before
we can just rewrite it under this form
just by applying basically
multiplication by minus 1 to have the
right
relational operator and by
using the equality node v is equal to 1
minus v
to make sure that all coefficients are
positive integers
so there are some fun facts with a
pseudo boolean constraint
as this one for example here without any
assignment
we can see that this constraint
propagates c
to true so indeed if c is not
satisfied we can see that the
maximum sum we can get on the left hand
side
would be 8 and since we need at least 10
here
c as indeed to be satisfied to satisfy
the constraint
so here we can see that a pb constraint
can propagate truth value without any
assignment
and basically a pb constraint can
propagate multiple
choose value at different decision
levels since for instance here
if we satisfy c it's not enough to
satisfy the constraints so later on we
will need
to satisfy another letter that may be
propagating
and actually this constraint here is
equivalent to
c and the constraint in which c has be
said at this time
which may be more easier easily written
as c and a or b
and what is interesting to see here is
that for instance
in this representation not d
uh oh sorry it's a or not it should be a
or not b actually here
and what we can see is that noddy does
not appear in this representation
and i will come back to this observation
later on in this
talk
so let us now consider our original
principle formula i told you
before so to represent this problem
we will use boolean variables p i j
to denote that the pigeon i is put in
all j and
to state that pigeon i should be in that
you know all we just say that for each
pigeon
i it must be in at least one of
the old j using this
constraint here which is actually
equivalent to a clause
and to say that each hole cannot use
more than one pigeon
we will use the atmosphere constraint
here for each hole
to represent uh the this um
this fact and then we will
be able to normalize it as i presented
before
and now let us say we can prove
unsatisfiability on this formula
so first let's make it by end
with so on this example so first
as i said we will normalize the
atmosphere constraints in order to make
sure that all
constraints are normalized
and then we will just add
if we add all these constraints so
basically by adding constraints
i mean we add the left-hand side
together and the right hand sides
together
and when a lead table and its negation
are present we they just cancel out by
producing one
and with this addition we get this
constraint here
if we now add the constraint 5 plus the
constraint 6
then we get here 3 greater or equals to
4 which is obviously false and this
is here how we prove the satisfiability
of the pig journal
prince on this speed general formula
return using
boolean constraints so here i
want to stress out that the constraints
are indeed
also the boolean constraints and in
theory it is
constraints are often represented in cnf
i mean with clauses
because we want to um to compare the
proof system under the same input
so um
and here from a theory point of view we
do we
do not want our codings we do not want
well we want to have the same
constraints
and we need somehow to recover
the cardinality constraints if we start
from
the the original closes
and daniel will later on talk on how we
can
recover such constraints
but in practice the way the constraints
are expressed matters
in the sense that for instance it is
easier
to read uh pseudo boolean constraints
for instance
the atmosphere one constraint is easier
to read than the
equivalent conjunction of clauses
and also the number of constraints is
different because we need
several clauses to represent that minus
one constraint we have
and if we have uh other constraints that
are not closest we can use different
inference rules so for instance
using the cutting plans proof system to
make the reasoning
and in practice it is very important to
have pb a constraints
in pb solvers because if a pb solver is
even a cna formula as input
it will simply behave as a slow set
solver because
it has many data structures
to deal with suitable and concern that
will not be used since
we only have clauses here
so let us now see how the solvers
actually reason
on sudo boolean constants
and in many cases in particular in the
case of stat4j
the proof system that you use is the one
which is known as generalized resolution
which is composed of these two rules
here so the first rule is a
constellation rule
which states that if we have a little
in a constraint and the negation of this
literal in another constraint we can
combine these two constraints
in order to eliminate the literal l
and this will produce a constant since l
plus not l is equal to one
so here what we do is we multiply this
constraint by beta
we multiply this constraint by alpha and
the concentrate is this one
with the constant produced by the
addition of l
and not l and the other word simply
state that
if coefficients are greater than the
degree
then we can just replace the coefficient
by the degree
and this will preserve equivalence
and with these two rules here
we can implement a conflict-driven
constraint learning algorithm which will
combine reasons and conflicts with these
tools to derive new constraints
so let us see uh how it works in this
example
so suppose first that we have this
assignment you know
so here red literals means that the
literals are falsifying while green
intervals mean
that the literals are satisfied
so if now c is falsified in this
constraint here
we can see that node b must be
satisfied to satisfy the constraint
since otherwise
it only remains three on this side so
not b is propagated here and we say that
this constraint
is a reason for not b but now if we look
at this
other constraints we can see that the
left hand side
is only equal to 5 why we need 6 and it
is not possible
to have this 6 here so this constraint
is conflictual
so what we can do here is to perform a
constellation so as
to eliminate b so
here is what we here is what we do
so basically here since the coefficient
of node b is 6 and the coefficient of b
is 4 here we can just multiply this
constraint by 2
to get 12 for node b and this
constrained by 3 so that we can
we get 12 for b and this will indeed
eliminate
the coefficient b and we get the
constraints
we have below but now if we look
at the left hand side we can see that
we have 15 here and it is still possible
to have six so we have in total
21 here so this constraint is no longer
conflicting
so we have broken a cdc environment
which
which states that when we combine reason
and configs we
preserve the conflict so we need to find
a way to restore this conflict
and this is achieved
by the weakening wall so this fall
we'll have to remove a little from a
constraint by decreasing
the degree of this constraint so for
instance here
if we want to eliminate l we just remove
it
and decrease the degree by the
coefficient of l
we cannot also partially weaken the
literal
by decreasing oh sorry i have an example
for this
so um here if we want to weaken
c away we just decrease the
degree by 3 and we get this constraint
here
and for a partial weakening we can
just decrease the coefficient and the
degree by the same amount
so here for instance we decrease the
coefficient of l by k
and the degree and here we can decrease
the coefficient of b by two
and we by we can also decrease the uh
the degree by two to get this constraint
which is
entailed by the original construct
so this rule can be applied and we will
see
uh later how to
preserve conflicts but there are
actually many different ways
to apply it to preserve conflicts
so the original approach is to just
weaken away literals
from the reason and we repeat the
operation
until we have the conflict we get a
conflicted constraint thanks to the
application of this saturation one
indeed if we just tweak and well it
works in itself it will not
modify the conflict status
of the constraints it will be actually
the application of the saturation rule
that will guarantee to derive a
conflicting constraint
but here with this operation we need to
repeat multiple times
to just weaken saturate check whether
the conflict is preserved and redo
until we have preserved the conflict so
this is the
the cost of this operation is not
negligible in practice
so we need another solution which takes
advantage of this property given by
dickson which say
that if the coefficient of the literal
to be cancelled out
is equal to one in at least the conflict
of the other reason
then we know that the derived constraint
will be conflicting
so the idea is just to make sure that
this coefficient will be equal to one
thanks to the application of the
weakening rule
our first approach is to weaken a way
ineffectively tables
so these three tables are those that do
not play a role in the conflict
which is also quite sim which is also
different
compared to set solvers because in
clauses all literals
in the clause are play a role in either
the propagation or
the conflict for this clause
so we can in the case of pb consent we
can
we can and effectively table the way and
let's see this on an example
so let us suppose that we have this
constraint under this current partial
assignment
so here we can see that node b has to be
propagated because
otherwise we will only have a
d and e that remain and they will not
be able with the not a already satisfied
to
produce the six we want but
if we need to propagate uh not b it's
really because of
falsified literals actually because
satisfied literals do not
impact the fact that the constraint is
conflicting or not it's really
classified little so here's the idea is
to weaken away
all ineffective intervals and to apply
the saturation rule
and this will guarantee that the
coefficient
of the little role of the propagated
literal here
which is not b will be one since
actually
using this approach will always derive
the clause
and there is also something that is
quite interesting is that
actually some falsified literals may
also be ineffective so for instance if
we have this conflicting constraint in
which all intervals are falsified
then we can choose one of the
literals that has coefficient one so for
instance let's say
c and this little is again
is ineffective so we can also have
chosen b or f
so it's it depends on what
maybe we can use heuristics to choose um
which literals to weaken away and here
indeed
if we can see a way we get this clause
which is still conflicting
and this approach is actually equivalent
to
the approach implemented in solvers such
as satellite or sat4a resolution
which lazily ensure closes to use a
resolution-based reasoning
during conflict analysis instead of a
cutting plane's
reasoning but it is actually quite
slower
because the way it is computed is not
the same
roman question yes
so if you go back to
this example the the so the the fact
that you can
remove c and still have a conflict uh
do you mean is there like did you have
some algorithmic way of deciding this or
you're just illustrating that we could
have done this and you leave open
like what would be the procedure for
identifying such
so basically the idea
is that
we can we can explore in this case
if its coefficient is strictly less than
the degree
okay and it will so basically we just
algorithmically speaking we we can away
all literals that are not falsified
and then we can apply um the weakening
progressively to uh if the
if we can away a literal with
coefficient lesser than the degree we
know that we will not derive
a tautology and since all literals are
falsified we know that it will
remain conflicting
i see because you're saying yeah
because since the coefficient is smaller
than the degree i mean it's
it's not only c is failing to contribute
enough someone else must also be failing
so even if you remove c then you you can
there's still blame to go around for the
other guys and that's why you still have
a conflict
yes okay got it thanks
so another way to get
a coefficient of one for the
coefficient on which the constellation
rule will be applied
is the approach proposed in rounding set
which is
to apply the division rule so as to make
sure
that the coefficient of
the propagated or conflicting
literal will be equal to one by dividing
by its coefficients
and to make sure to praise of conflict
the idea is to weaken away
some and falsify later and i will show
you this on an example so first
i want to show that the division rule
simply states that we can
divide all coefficients and the degree
by the same amount
and then we round up a coefficient and
degrees
so um the approach proposed in rounding
set
here if we want for instance to uh
perform the cancellation
on the literal b here
so the coefficient of b is seven
so here we have some coefficients that
are not divisible by seven
and the approach of running that is to
weaken away
all unfalsified intervals that for which
the coefficient is not divisible
by 7. so here the idea
is to weaken away a since 8 is not
divisible by 7
and f and we will get this constraint
here
then this constraint is divided by the
coefficient
of b which is seven and we get this
clause here
and another approach may be to apply
partial weakening
so for instance here instead of
completely weakening
a aoa we can just we can it partially so
that it's coefficient become
seven instead of eight so we just
instead of
decreasing the coefficient of the degree
sorry
by eight we will decrease it by one
only so
actually there are many different
variants of this strategy because
as i said the idea of all these
strategies is to have the
coefficient of the literal and with the
cancellation rule is applied
equal to one in at least one of the
constraints
so that we can either apply the
weakening
on the conflicting constraint on the
reason
or on both so what we can see here
is that for the different weakening
strategies i presented here
the more the one having the
best performance is saturday partial
running set which is
an implementation of running set in
sat4j which is this partial weakening
and which supplies the
weakening on both constraints then we
have
the implementation of rounding set
inside for j and the weakening
of finish activator in both constraints
so here we we can see that in a sense
applying the weakening on both
constraints
is in general better than applying it in
only one constraint
and one thing which is quite surprising
here is that
the after
after having applied on both the best
strategies
are applying only on the conflicting
constraints
and this is surprising because since the
early development of pb solvers
the weakening has only been applied on
the reason and here these experiments
suggest that it is actually better to do
this on the conflict
so and now that we have thanks to the
weakening
we know that we can preserve conflicts
and restore this environment
but we need now to know when to stop
the analysis sorry just another sorry
for being slow
another question if you go back
so the the if if we look at these
plots the point is that for all of these
solvers you're taking
one one rule one strategy and you're
using it consistently
yes yes and then you have the virtual
best solver that is
beating everything by quite a bit
so just to point out if we for the
i'm thinking for the simon's program as
a like your
research question is like how if some
additivity could help close the gap
between the vbs and all these fixed
alternatives
right yes and maybe
one thing we thought about is maybe to
to try to use some other installation
techniques
to try to combine this
these strategies by trying to identify
which seems to be the best
and to maybe combine the best of all
strategies to
reduce the vbs
so now
to when we have preserved the conflict
thanks to the application of the
weakening rule
we need to know when to stop the
analysis because
inside solvers we know that we can stop
when the derived clause contains only
one
literal that is assigned at the current
decision level
and we know that the back jump is
performed
at the decision level which is the
deepest
except of course the current one and we
know that we can back
up up to this decision level
but in case of pseudo boolean solvers
we have no such syntactical detection
actually
because to identify
the highest back jump level that we to
which we can back jump
we need to consider the weights of the
literal
since a suitable
construct as i said before may propagate
literals at different decision levels
so we need to identify the decision
level
the first decision level at which this
circumstance propagates at least one
interval
and thus this is we need to do some more
computations compared to a
set solving so this is yet another
variant
of cdcl that we have broken here
so but we have also a necklace hill
in the cotti plains proof system
which is the fact that some
literals may be irrelevant in the
constraint produced by the proof system
so here for instance
if we want to cancel d out
in these two constraints we will just
add them since the coefficient is
already the same and we get this
constraint here
and we can see that
the literal c is irrelevant in the sense
that its truth value does not have an
impact on the truth value
of the of the constraints and actually
if you recall the one of my first
examples
in which we have written
a constraint then one literal at
disappear
when we add the representation c
or a and not b and this is typically
the case when we have irrelevant
intervals in a pseudo boolean constraint
so this is what i said about uh
irrelevant
literal that does not have an impact on
the true value of the constraints
but what is interesting here is that
irrelevant interval may be removed from
the constraint while preserving
equivalence so here c
can simply be removed and move
so we made some experiments and found
out that
many relevant liters actually produced
by set4j
in many different
families of benchmarks so here we have
box plots with states for each family of
instances
how many irrelevant literals were
produced so
for each box we have the minimum and
maximum
which are presented here and the
the horizontal bars here are the
so the the cartilage of the
distribution and the horizontal bar in
the middle is a median
so we can see that we can have many
irrelevant tutorials produced during
conflict
analysis and sometimes more than 10 000
for instance in the case of
euclid pb benchmark so
irrelevant literals are not only
theoretic problems
they are indeed produced in pb solvers
but the problems is really when these
littles become artificially relevant
so let's see what it means on this
example here
we have um so here's the constraint i
presented before with the literal c
which is irrelevant and we have here
this
other constraint in which c is also
irrelevant
for the similar reasons as for this
constraint
but if we combine these two constraints
to eliminate the literal a
we get this constraint here which is
equivalent to this clause and of course
this is since this is a clause c is
relevant
since in all topological non-total
logical clauses
and non-contra sorry
since for non-tethological clauses all
intervals are always
relevant but here
observe that if the irrelevant
lc had been removed in the original
construct it would not appear
in the derived constraint here so we
would get
the clause b or d instead of the class b
or c or d which is stronger than the
clause
we derived which means that because of
irrelevant intervals
we can produce weaker constraints during
conflict analysis
but the problem is that detecting
whether
a literal is irrelevant is npr
so we can not just say okay we maybe
some literals will be relevant we will
remove them
and we will have a stronger constraint
no this
this is more complicated so we
propose an incomplete algorithm to
remove
uh irrelevant literals from the
constraints
and to this end we will use this
reduction
to the subset sum problem
so here we have that literal l is
irrelevant
in the constraint here if
this equality has no solution for k
in 1 to alpha so let's
me x let me explain this a little bit so
intuitively if we have if
here we have indeed a solution to this
equality
this means that this solution will not
in itself be a solution
to this constraint here because the
we do not have delta we have less than
delta since
since we have delta minus k
but if we satisfy l
at this point then we will go from a
model
from a counter model sorry of the
constraint to a model of the constraint
since alpha plus delta minus k because
of
this interval will be greater than delta
so the interval will be relevant
so this is the intuition behind this
reduction here
so here for instance say
c is irrelevant in this constraint
because it is not possible
to have one for this equality
and two for this equality
so we can with this reduction to subset
them
apply the classical dynamic programming
algorithm
to detect whether an interval is
irrelevant
or not and
more interestingly since this algorithm
compute all possible sums
we will know in this in a single run of
the algorithm whether there exists
a solution for one of the equalities to
consider
and this will be in pseudo-polynomial
time
thanks to the dynamic programming
algorithm
the problem with this algorithm is that
it depends
on the value of the degree of the
constraint
and in practice the degree may be very
big
in the derived pb constraint so it would
be
not efficient enough to simply solve
subset sum on the constraints
so we need an incomplete approach to
solve
this subset some instances and to this
end we will use a
modulo approach because what we want to
know
is to make sure that a literal
is irrelevant before removing it so
basically what we want is to make sure
that the literally we remove available
event
we just allowed to consider as relevant
literals that are irrelevant because
what this allows to
simply remove literals without
considering its coefficients
as i represent in the next slide
so we can allow to miss irrelevant
literals
and this can be applied thanks to
an application of certain algorithm
modulo fixed number
so basically here instead of
computing the subset sum
the possible sums the real possible sums
we will compute them modulo the chosen
number
and the intuition is that if
the sum exists then it will also exist
modulo
and similarly if no sum exists it will
not exist modulo so
if we cannot find the solution to the
subset sum problem modulo the chosen
number
then we are sure that the literal will
be irrelevant
and we can even compute
the subset some solutions on several
numbers
to make sure that um well to
improve the accuracy of the algorithm
since
the probability of
making an error will decrease if we have
different numbers
since basically if as soon as it is not
possible
to find
a sum modulo one of the numbers we know
that
it is not possible for and it will not
be possible
without considering the modulo here
so now when we know that a literal is
irrelevant
we can just remove it
while preserving equivalence in the
literal are relevant and there are
two ways to do so so here if we consider
this example
we can just locally assign the literal
c to zero since
we know that it is irrelevant and if we
do and if we do so
we just actually remove it from the
constraints and we get
this constraint here
can also assign it to one which is
actually equivalent to the weakening
approach
to get this constraint here which is
which will actually because of the
saturation will be equivalent to a or b
and we can see that this constraint is
also equivalent to a aobi so airsign is
no different
but in practice there may be some
difference
and some construct it may be preferable
to use one of the approach or another
one
and we use a heuristic to decide
which strategy to apply because as i
said
sometimes it may be better to use one
strategy and
some other times it may be better to use
another one
so we implemented the removal
uh in set4j and
we can see here the difference the
impact on the size of the proof bid by
the solder so here we consider the size
of the proof
because the algorithm remained costly
so we and we wanted to
really evaluate the impact of the
relevant literals on the strength of the
reasoning
made by the solver so we can see that
there is no clear difference
because there are points over and below
and are
quite equally uh divided into
below and above the the red line here
but what is interesting here is this
particular family which has verticals
cover instances
and we will consider them more
specifically
so what we did here is that we generated
more instances of this family to see
whether
the trend is confirmed and indeed we can
see that
the number of constellation step
applied during conflict analysis is
exponentially
smaller when we remove irrelevant
littles
and actually if we look at the
behavior of sat4j on this family
we can see that the first constraint
learned by the solver has this form here
where n is a scale parameter of the
instance
and what we can see is that all literals
x 1 to x and minus 1 are irrelevant
since they are not enough to
make this side greater than n
and x if x is satisfied
it obviously satisfies the constraint
and actually this constraint is
equivalent to the unit clause x
and what is also interesting on this
family is that no other irrelevant
literals are detected
in the other constraint derived by set4j
which means that
even fewer relevant literals produced at
the very beginning
of the exploration of the search space
may lead to the prediction of an
exponentially larger
proof and this
tends to sugges this suggests that it is
really important to
um find a way to avoid the production of
irrelevant intervals
since detect exam is very costly and
this is what is
uh shown on this scatter plot here where
we
compare the runtime of the solver with
and without
the detection of irrelevant intervals
really in terms of times here and we can
see that the solver is much slower in
general
when this uh the removal of the relevant
literal is activated
because of the cost of the algorithm so
here we instead of removing them
it would be very interesting to avoid
producing them in the first place
and a possibility is to actually use
one of the rules i presented before
about
the weakening of ineffective literals
so recall that for instance we have
ineffective literals here
because here they are not
falsified and here this one
has a coefficient that is lower than the
degree
so in this case we can consider them
as locally irrelevant
in the sense that if we uh
simplify the constraint here for
instance
by saying that okay not a is satisfied
so
we can say that this is equal to 3 so we
move it to the right hand side and
we get three here this literally simply
removes it is not
it is not falsified
it is falsified sorry and
the constraints that remain is actually
strain of b three not b plus d plus c
greater than
three and d and not e are
um irrelevant in this case
and um we can just say that they are
irrelevant under the current partial
assignment
whereas uh the euro adventurers are
presented before
were globally relevant independently of
the current assignment
and here it is easy to detect the
ineffective intervals compared to the
globally relevant intervals so we can
make sure that irrelevant titles are
removed by the
weakening of ineffective literals
however
here we are we must
apply the weakening wall whereas for a
relevant interval we can just
we could just simply remove literals
from the constraints
because here we are not sure that the
literals are irrelevant
and indeed for instance not a d and e
are relevant in the constraint they are
only ineffective so we this is why we
need the weakening
rule instead of the simple removal
but this leads to the inference of
weaker constraints since as i said we
only derived clauses here
and the main idea of removing irrelevant
literals
were it was in the first place to
have stronger constraints so here we
we need to find uh
just middle between removing
uh all relevant intervals and
removing more than the relevant literals
which is
uh too
it's too much in terms of
maintaining the strength if you want to
maintain the strength of the constraints
okay so now we've seen that we need to
um
adapt some things if we want to uh
the our the cutting-based proof system
to fit
in the cdcl architecture but we can also
further adapt pb solvers to the cdcl
architecture
because here so for the moment we mostly
consider the conflict analysis
procedure but there are also other
important features in cd cells such as
the decision heuristics
the deletion of land clauses and
the restart policy
and it is well known that these features
are very important for that solvers to
be efficient
so we need to adapt them
in pb solvers because
currently most of these heuristics are
reused as is from set solvers
without considering the particular
properties of pb constraints
and what we found out is that if we
consider the size of the coefficients
all the current partial assignment when
computing
the heuristics or choosing the which
constraint to delete and when to restart
then we can significantly improve the
solver and in particular stat4j
in this case so if we consider for
instance
the uh the implementation of the
generalized resolution in sat4j
we can see that from the
the default implementation which uses
strategies generated from set solving we
can
incrementally improve it until the
best combination we have here
and i will present later on which are
the
different strategies here and we have
uh similar observations for the
implementation of running set in set4j
and the implementation
of funding set inside fajr with the use
of the partial weakening wall
used to maintain conflicts during
conflict analysis
here is a comparison of sat4a j
with a running set and the different
particular of the different
implement the different strategies
implemented
in inside4j and we can see that
from the default implementations of side
footage analyze resolution and the two
implementation of running set in sat4j
we can almost reach the
the performance of fronting set only by
applying
the best just the combinations of the
best strategies
and thanks if we in addition to this
if we uh compute if you compute now
if we use um
both versions of sat4j which combine
the in parallel so cutting place basic
difference and resolution-based
insurance
we have quite competitive results in
sat4j here
both because of the resolution proof
system which is
efficient which remains efficient on
some benchmarks
and thanks to the different
adaptations of the strategies i just
presented briefly in the previous slide
so that's it for the first part of this
presentation
so if you have any question please let
me know
thanks a lot roman uh so there was
in fact one question that was discussed
in the chat
already and but i'm bringing it up just
because i don't think the chat makes it
into
the recording that is posted afterwards
so mata
sauce asked has it been tried to use
statistics and machine learning
to supervise learn the best strategy to
get closer to vbs so this
he was asking long ago in the context of
these
um i think in the context of these
different
weakening strategies but of course you
could also
consider it in the context of this
bumping also
and daniel liber asked that this has
not been done um
and i guess yeah so i don't know if you
want to add anything to this
other questions to ask you well
actually we have some
we have a perspective the idea of
using uh machine learning to try to find
the best strategies maybe using as i
said
earlier automatic algorithm
configuration or other
other strategies that we have in mind
but this is uh
on our to-do list saying
i mean one can also discuss i guess
whether whether you want to throw
machine learning at this or whether we
want to understand what's happening i
mean you could also imagine that you
some
have some principled way of of choosing
in between different rules
like for instance if you have a several
different alternatives
at every step in the conflict analysis
maybe you try all of them
now you get a bunch of candidate
constraints and you compare them and
check which one
looks best and then continue with this
i think this might be as if so i'm not
very good at mixed interior linear
programming but as far as i understand
when they do cut
generation for instance they um
generate lots and lots and lots of
different cuts and then they look at
them and have some heuristics for saying
oh i'll i like the
these ones they will will keep these and
we'll throw away the rest
yeah i think we haven't been doing this
in saturn
any i have tons of questions but you
know i shouldn't
hog all the time i'm looking in the chat
or if
someone wants to unmute and ask anything
you know you know if you don't do it
then i will ask another question soon
okay so maybe while while people are
thinking another question if you go back
to the plot that you just had
do you yeah do you know what
this i mean it's it's a very flattering
picture i guess
for rounding sat so i shouldn't complain
but i'm
wondering this might also be because
you're measuring
running time so i wonder if would you
have
the same plot but but using some
proxy for for you know the quality of
the proof search such as if you plot the
number of conflicts instead would it
look the same
or would the solvers be much much much
closer
well i not sure i made
it for all experiments
i made some
at some point but i'm not sure i i i
think i made it for to compare different
variants in selfridges but not with
surrounding sets during
well while i was making these
experiments but it should not be
too hard to uh to draw
other plots i still have all uh all laws
so it
it should be uh easily easy to uh
to those other plots and take this
because it's it i mean it could still be
that
maybe for some reason rounding that is
really good or it could be that
no no if you're if if they would be like
if you would have a
level playing field then actually these
latest
optimizations of yours are actually way
better
yeah so this is someone is asking
how much paul beam is is asking how much
of the difference is is java versus c
plus plus java versus c plus plus and
daniel is asking probably a factor
three four
in um there was a version of mini set
written by
custom sims called jaminisat and
that was reproducing exactly the the
behavior of mini set and there was a
factor of
3.25 or something like this uh
between the gemini set and mini sat so
but uh it's complicated to to say that
because
there are things to you cannot really do
uh in java that you can do in
c and c plus plus so there are features
that i mean presented
missed talk uh the first week that are
hardly
done i don't know how to do them on
with java so i mean um
you have to pay a price but there is
also the just in time compiler that also
on some cases also does a pretty good
job so
well it's um
then well okay uh it it's
yes there are cases uh clearly set for
there is not for
there for speed right but um
well i mean so it's it's not uh i think
it's it's
quite okay uh and maybe something we
should mention is
so uh there is a difference between
running set
one and running set two based on the use
of arbitrary
precision arithmetic and i think this is
something we have in java we know that
it's slow
but this is what we use and
so sat4j could be more efficient using
just primitive types but then there
would be issues with
with overflows so uh
yeah it's a trade of uh
yeah but you would see so i mean you
you'd eliminate
you you'd get us some feeling for what's
going on
by just comparing conflict counts
because that's that's somehow a proxy or
or you know that like the total
some of the length of all conflict
analysis or something that would tell
you something
so there are a number of comments in the
chat that i'm again reading out because
i don't think they make it onto the
recording otherwise regarding the
speed up from java to c plus plus
uh kieran mccreach is saying that for
subgraph solving
uh which is more bit parallel the factor
is over 10 and then kiran had another
comment
actually i don't know if you want to
unmute and elaborate here and
regarding this question of this
heuristic figuring out whether a pseudo
boolean constraint is good or bad
there are some heuristics used in some
constraint programming solvers for when
to use strong propagation for linear
equalities
do you want to elaborate yes so um
uh i'll talk about this more tomorrow in
the
encoding session but um
for linear inequalities um doing
the perfect propagation is is np hard
it's again it's a subset some kind of
thing
um but some solvers will look and see
okay if
um the coefficients are small of a
number of variables are small according
to some
carefully calculated set of heuristics
it will turn the
linear equalities into what's called a
table constraint
um which is effectively a dnf
representation of the constraints in
some forms so
um this is something a constraint
programming solvers do
automatically they will uh rewrite the
constraints that you put in
um might be worth having a look at
the heuristics that cp solvers use to
decide when to do this as well
[Music]
right this is also a good uh time to to
advertise
uh that because this encoding question
also came up as roman mentioned if you
have a problem
and you want to use a pseudo boolean
solver please make sure not to encode it
in conjunctive normal form
because that's a very bad idea try to
write it as as
more you know natural pseudo boolean
constraints then this is connected also
to the question of encodings and there
will be a
a workshop seminar tomorrow at
5 30 central european time i guess
about precisely different encoding
problems
any other questions for roman before we
take a
10 minute break
so i think not then why don't we so so
it's now three minutes 33 minutes past
the hour
in whatever time zone you're in except
if you're in india
i guess then it's three minutes past the
full hour
so you know even you're trying to be
generic and still you can't be generic
enough
so let's reconvene in 10 minutes from
now for those of us who wants to go
even deeper into the pseudo boolean
solving deep dive
okay but for now we're taking a break
thank you
so we are preparing to restart in
just a few seconds we're having
fascinating discussions about time zones
in the chat while we're waiting
nepal is apparently 45 minutes
off the standard
time zones together with chatham island
and austral
australian central western time
there you go um any other
questions that have arisen while we were
having a break
before we let daniel and roman lose
again
feel free to unmute especially now i
think during the second half people
who and if you want to ask a question
and you can't because you're
a an attendee rather than a panelist
then there's a way of promoting you so
that you can
unmute and speak just send a message in
the chat and we'll take care of it
in no time
but i see no questions so i guess daniel
that means it's over to you again
okay so let's now
make a deeper dive into set4j
and first i want i would like to
come back to the fine tuning of sat4j
with a different strategy by
giving some more details on how we
implemented
the variance of the cdcl strategies
so let's consider again a conflict
analysis with this
two constraints here so first we say
that
okay b is satisfied c is falsified
d is falsified which propagates not a
and not f and then we have
here a conflict so we apply the
constellation rule to derive
new constraints and here this construct
is learned because
if we come back to a
decision level here 2 we can see that
we propagate a here
yes we propagate a at this point
so now we can see that uh
the pb constraints that are involved in
the conflict analysis and the
constraints that is learned at the end
of conflict analysis
are quite different compared to the
clauses that are handled by
set servers so first let's see
how vcds and evc's in the case of
mini set-based solvers can be uh
changed to taking into account the
properties of pb constraints
and first i will briefly recall on how
it was so
basically all variables that are
encountered during conflict analysis
get bumped uh to improve to increase
their score
their e-visit score so if we do this
for a pseudo boolean constant we will
bump
all variables of the reason here for
instance
so not a not f d and e will be bumped
at some point
so we will increase and increment the
score
but so as i said this does not
this is not exactly the same thing as
foreclosing since
the literals do not have the same role
in the construct
so an approach that has been that has
been proposed in um
for adopting these seeds is to take into
account
only the original cardinality
constraints
and the problem is that if we only
consider original cardinality
constraints we do not consider
loan constraints and non-cardinality
constraints and any general pb
constraint
so this does not solve our problem
of adapting vcds to pb constraints
so here we can take into account the uh
coefficients
into uh three new strategies which are
uh
bumping the degree of um
the constraints so basically here we
we just estimate the it's a raw estimate
of the uh of the
number of closes because this is how it
is
it works for cardinality constraints
since the degree is equivalent
is equal to the number of clauses needed
to represent the calculating constraint
and this is what is done in the this
adaptation of dixon and we just wanted
to
generalize this this strategy here
we can also bump the coefficient to try
to uh
estimate the role of the coefficients so
here
a a and f for instance will be bound by
three in this case
dne and because
we can also make a ratio of
the degree by the coefficient
if we want to generalize both the
approach
of distance to bomb by the degree and to
take into account
the coefficient of the return and do the
role of the
of the literal in the constraint
so we implemented
all these strategies in central j and
also
another strategy which is the
ratio a coefficient by degree
which is actually an approach which was
proposed in pueblo
which is instead of
dividing the degree by the coefficient
we just divide the coefficient by the
degree
which estimates uh the
the impact the the role of the literal
in the the relative
impact of the letter in the constraint
compared to all the other literals
and we can see that this is the only
strategy that is better than
the default approach when we consider at
least coefficients
but this is coefficients are not the
only difference between pb constraint
and clauses
and in particular assignments do not
play the same role
with pv constraints and clauses so here
for instance there are unassigned a
little
in the reason they are satisfied
literally in the reasons that were not
propagated at this point
and this is quite different compared to
clauses when
because when we have a reason we know
that all literal as are falsified
except one which is the one that is
propagated
so we need to uh know which literals are
involved in the propagation
so we have that we know that certified
intervals are
most most likely to be involved in the
constraint but there are there is also
the notion of effective letters i
presented before
and we know that some uh falsified
letters may
do not have an impact
on the propagation so we consider
other strategies so which is
which are the bumper sign so we only
bump
literals that are assigned by the
current assignment bump falsified
which bump only details that are
falsified and
bump effective which only bump literals
that are effective
so here um
so i forgot to say that we also bump uh
the literal that is uh
propagated so this little will always be
satisfied since it is propagated
but it is involved in the conflict since
propagating digital leads to a conflict
so this is why
we also bump uh not f here
would you remind us what an effective
variable is
yes so it's so
an effective variable is always first
falsified
and if we remove all
by weakening all literals that are not
falsified
if coefficients of literals
are smaller than the degree then we
consider these littles are ineffective
so stated otherwise
ineffective literals a little for which
if we weaken
this literal the way the conflict is
preserved all the propagation is
preserved here
so because the intuition behind this is
that we want
to bump really the literals that are
involved in the conflict
and effectively all are really those
that are involved in the conflict
and when we implemented all these
strategies
in sat4j we can see that actually all
these new strategies are
better than the default
implementation which bump all literals
that encounter during conflict analysis
whatever the current assignment
and we can see that indeed
the the idea of this strategy is to um
really bump letters that are involved in
the conflicts
uh allow us to uh improve the solver
because
uh each time we get more precise on what
we mean by involved in the conflicts we
in indeed uh
improve the performance of the solver
here and as we can see the bump
effective strategy is indeed the best of
the strategies we have here
and just to check that we're on the same
page and to understand that the point is
that if we look at these
three strategies that you had on your
last slide
in the conflict in the in the context of
conflict-driven clause learning there is
no distinction because they're all the
same
it's impossible to tell which one of
these three cdcl does because they're
all the same
but when you lift from clauses to sudo
boolean constraints then you see the
difference
yes indeed
okay thanks
so another way to adapt the
classical cdcl strategies in sudo
boolean solvers
is to consider the measure for the
quality of learn constraints
so basically in set solvers at some
point we need to delete clauses because
uh if we have too many uh learned
clauses
then it would slow down unit propagation
and use a lot of memory
and we need to remove some of them
and to choose which to remove we need a
quality measure
and this quality measure may also be
used to
trigger restarts as proposed in glucose
for instance
but once again
if we use the quality measures used in
set solvers
they do not consider the properties of
pb constraints
and we can adapt them to
better measure the the quality of land
pb constraints
so first we have the size of the clauses
which is a knife quality measure because
the longer this close
the lower strands especially from a unit
propagation
viewpoint because we need to have many
uh
little specified before the constraint
propagates something
but this is not the case actually uh
for pb constraints because
as i said we may have many literals but
one that is propagated immediately
without making any assignments so the
size does not
reflect its propagation power
and this is because actually the size of
pb constraints
also takes into account the coefficients
that appear in this constraint
so here for instance we have that
there are different coefficients
so we need to take them into account and
they may also become very big
also so this is a another
point to be uh considered because if
coefficients become very big
we need to use arbitrary precision
encodings instead
of fixed precision encodings and the
we need to perform more complicated
arithmetic operations because they are
not
executed directly by the processor but
we need uh algorithms to perform these
operations
so we also do not want to have
coefficients with big coefficients so a
possibility is to consider
a constraint with big coefficients of
bad quality
and to this end we may consider for
instance the degree
of the constraint so here for instance
it's 7 because
since we have the saturation rule we can
know that the degree of the constraint
is an upper bound
of the coefficients in the constraint so
with only the degree we can evaluate the
size of the coefficients
in the in the constraints and we can
either consider the view as a quality
measure or the size in terms of number
of bits required to represent it
to measure the quality of the constraint
we can also generalize
the lbd measure of
clauses to pb constraints
so here the idea is to consider the
number of decision levels that appear in
a clause
the problem is that in if we look at
this constraint for instance
there is a literal that is unassigned so
what is its
decision level so we need to to take
this into account to define an lbd
measure for
pb constraints and also there are
satisfied details
whereas in when we consider lbd we
measure the
we either measure it on the conflicting
constraint or constraints that propagate
depending on whether the contract is
learned or
is used as a reason again and in this
case there is only
one literal that is a at most one
network that is
satisfied which is the one that is
propagating and if it is propagated it
means also
that there is a falsified database at
the same decision level
in this construct
so we need to take this into account in
some way
and there are many different so
it should be five here because i added
one more
after this so the different
lbd measures maybe the lbd computed over
assigned intervals so we do not uh
take into account it all that are
unassigned because there is no decision
level for such details
the lbds measure works similarly
but in instead of ignoring
an assigned literals we say that okay
these letters are assigned at
some decision level that does not exist
but we consider this as
a same decision level for all literals
the lbdd for different yes it's
we consider that all unassigned literals
are assigned at a different decision
level so
we can't all unassign letters and we add
this to the lvda
and then we compute either the lbd of a
falsify intervals
or other effective literals to take into
account
the fact that this literal are more
involved in the conflict of the
propagation
so with this new strategy so
the new definitions of lbd for pb
constraint and
the quality measures depends on the size
of coefficients
we can decide new
deletion strategies for learner
constraints
because as for that solvers p because pv
solvers must
delete constraint but this is not as
needed
let's say as for set solvers at least
inside for j
because cutting base insurance is not is
much slower
than a resolution in front so the solver
in a sense
learns less constraints but the as a
since one constraint is equivalent to
many clauses in general
this kind of compensates the fact that
we learn a few constraints
but since we learned a few constraints
we do not there is less
impact of many constraints on the
efficiency of the solver
but still we implement the
long-constrained deletion to based on
the
different quality measures i presented
before
so based on the different led measures
and the
the degree of the constraint
and we also use the quality measures as
a restart policy
based on the additive restart proposing
glucose
which evaluates the quality of the
recently learned constraints
so here if the constraints
that are learned more recently are of
poor quality compared of all
the other constraints that have been
learned then we perform a restart
and once again we use the different
quality measures
to uh trigger restarts here
so we can see that for dilation there is
not a big impact
still it's all
better than the default but to a
little extent and quite interestingly
doing no dilation at all
is better than uh deleting based on the
activity of the constraint as in many
sets
which is a default
approach inside for j so we can see
yes yeah do you how aggressively
are you erasing constraints are you
using like
glucose settings for this
yeah yes i think uh
yes this is the same algorithm as in
miniset
so you just remove
half of the non-blocked constraints
[Music]
so means i think glucose are different
in this regard so
yeah but uh so um
we uh so i can cut to
the gesture why i'm asking is like if so
so
the way glucose does it roughly
give or take like after after n
conflicts glucose will have something
like square root and
constraints left in the in the clause
database that's like the rough scaling
glossing over some details now if
actually not deleting clauses at all
might be competitive then this sort of
raises the question well
you could interpolate between aggressive
deletion
and less aggressive deletion so
maybe there's a like a curve hiding
there that will
go much further to the right but this
i guess this would be a topic for
further future exploration
so here is for the
deletion strategies so
as we can see few impact at least inside
4g
well little impact in saturday uh for
this experiment
for restart we have also something
similar
and quite interestingly the the
picosatri stats uh
perform quite well which are the static
because that
strategy restart policy with inner and
outer restarts
which is quite competitive compared to
all the other even the lbd base
implemented in zed4j
and still the the size here
seems to matter for having a good
performance with restarts and if we
combine
we start and deletion since we they use
the same
quality measure we have that
the degrees the degrees remain uh
performance here and
the activity based so here are the
static restart policies which are
which are combined with a default
activity uh quality measures and
these are uh not so uh competitive
compared to zero but this this may
be due to the fact that the activity
based restart policy
is not really performance on the
benchmarks here
but still we can see that the vbs is
quite far from
all of these strategies and this is this
was also the case
for the restart policies so once again
there might be a
room for improvement here may be based
on automatic configuration algorithms
for instance
and so with all these
these strategies we have combined all of
them since they can be
combined and they are independent in
some way
we to try to get the best and
if we combine all of them in a saturday
we can see that
we improve the solver and especially
the fact that the the variant
of the bump strategies is the one with
the biggest impact
on uh on the solver and
combining this strategy with
the other allows to improve the server
but not enough to reach the vbs so
we there is some once again
some room for improvements here we need
to try to
identify what are also the interactions
between these heuristics since
they are still tightly linked in the
solver so maybe there
may be also interactions that we have
not taken into account that may also
explain why
we are not we do not read the vbs here
so here is uh once again the plot
that compares with other server and this
time there is also
all pseudo-boolean solvers of the latest
competition in 2016
so here we can see that sat4j is
quite competitive now with all these
strategies compared to all
state-of-the-art solvers but still
quite far from the first version of
france that's here
and it may be interesting to see whether
we can improve
the performance of running set with the
different strategies
present in here inside forte
so before letting daniel speak
about this point as an answer to a jacob
jacobs talk on the bootcamp week
maybe i will take some questions if
there are some
so there is some chat activity going on
which i will read out so it looks like
so so there are two differences from
that you could have from from
with with regard to minisetting glucose
when it comes to constraint deletion
but it seems like the number of
constraints that are kept is roughly as
in glucose
it should be squaring like square root
10 but but daniel points out that the
selection has been done on activity and
not on lbd-based measures
i hope we got this right yeah
so there are many different strategies
in
limb direction for strategies inside 4j
and
so for us it's a glucose if it's based
on lbd
and then do we have narrated the
the other one from activity from mini
sub so i don't think
[Music]
i don't remember that i mean this has
been more than
12 years ago but uh i think this is
really the
classical activity uh relation
of milliseconds that we have for the so
i think the very
i shouldn't it's very dangerous to
answer daniel when it comes to like
you know sat solving i'll i'll make a
fool out of myself immediately
uh but i'll try anyway so i i think
that like some very early versions of
minnesota you could
the question is how do you decide when
is the next time you're going to do a
database cleaning and if instead of
if instead of doing an additive increase
you would
increase the the time limit by say
multiplying by
you know 1.25 or something so that your
database
pruning becomes more and more infrequent
that would actually lead to a
linear scaling so that now after
after n conflicts you have
like theta of n uh constraints in your
database
and then you can play with the
multiplicative factor
to decide you know what what what the
linear factor is but this
might be worth
exploring especially if it seems like i
mean if if not erasing at all is
competitive
then this might be worth explaining like
you would clear out the bad
constraints but you'd keep much more
around and maybe that would be helpful
yeah yeah well we we have many different
ones because we
we even have so typically we are
what we call a timer that we'll just
look at how much memory you have or
other things so well we can we can
check and we can discuss this no problem
should i talk about any other questions
or
yeah that's what i wanted so
i don't see anything in the chat
let me just check
okay maybe we should talk about uh
recovering cardinality constraints
that sounds exciting why don't we do
that
exciting i don't know so uh for now
next time peace um
okay so one of the of the issue actually
we
we have uh with well we set for jay and
with many other uh systems is that
if you just uh uh try to solve
uh let's say the pigeon hole on on a cnf
it will just not work
and um and so this is
really painful because even people
trying to to play with story example
which probably
uh find the the closer representation
and so there is that issue that
okay we we need to it would be nice
because a human can do it
that a solver can just figure out from
the cnf
how to to prove efficiently
the thing uh
so uh so if we go back to the first
example that
roma showed you about um what we call
the human proof uh
for pigeonhole actually what you
you see that now you do not have really
the kinetic constraints what you have is
a
closer representation of the kinetico
train so for
for for the canity constraints uh p11
plus p21 plus
p31 less or equal to one actually you
have three clauses
uh for a for b and for c and so
what is really so what is really the
input
you should be you should be able to deal
with should be those clauses
and actually the first step uh you you
have to do
with juice clauses is to sum up the
the three clauses to get uh
observable and constrained and that
production content will get
two literals for p11 for p21 or for
p31 and from this pseudogram constraints
you can just divide them by two
and then you will recover your
cardinality constraints
so here um we should so they are written
uh greater or equal to two but this is
exactly the same thing as
negating all the literals and uh
strict uh less or at most one
okay and and then you can continue
with the the with the proof and then you
get uh your contradiction
so really the issue is how is it
possible
uh well is it possible in the sat solver
to
to to find out how to sum up
some of the clauses and then uh
how to apply the division because here
it works because
on the left hand side all the literals
do have the same coefficient and you are
you are going to um
from the you are going to round up the
degree
divided by by two which will get you two
and this is how you
you you get your um your candidate
concerns
and actually uh so uh we have been
discussing about
this with uh jacob when i was repeating
him
and um and so i i came back for
uh to launch and then we we started
working on this
so um and maybe next slide or not
and uh so just to give you an example
uh uh so this is we sat for day
if you take a pivotal problem with
android uh uh android one pigeons and
hundred holes
so it will be uh not possible to
to solve it if you take any version of
sat4j either
general life resolution of base and
resolution
but if you input if your input is
getting
uh is made of kinetic constraints then
uh
the system based on the resolution will
work
and so well i mean if you think about
constraint programming
they will tell you well constraints
matters so your
input should be the input
uh with with pre preserve as much
structure
as possible as much information as
possible
on the other hand uh we have our
colleagues from
theoretical from science saying well but
uh if you want to play with proof system
uh we should have the same uh input so
uh so the idea was okay can we find a
way
um well to to re recover
uh to retrieve those community
constraints
in the solver but definitely not in the
way a human would do it
and the the idea was to to to work on
this
and to do it uh as a pre-processing step
next time so the the thing is
yeah well i mean uh so we have
several uh one of the issue we have
is so we show i show you one uh what we
call the pairwise encoding
uh in the example but there are actually
many different ways to
encode cadentity constraints it depends
of
the degree depends if it's an equality
or if it's uh
on at most or at least
and so the many different people have
been working on many different encodings
which have different
strengths depending on what you want in
terms of number of variables the number
of
uh clauses in uh maintaining or not
a consistency and so on and so the issue
here is if you want to do to recover
your
your kinetic constraints from the cnf
in some ways you would have to be able
to uh
recognize all those encodings and new
ones and
and this is this is not well
this will be not working so the the
the approach was okay there is something
we do in
in sat that we do often it's unit
propagation
and so the the point is to try to
use unit propagation to try to recover
uh the canadian constraints
and the nice thing is that
in principle uh it should weigh it could
work for any encoding preserving at
consistency
and this is the the nice property well
this is in principle because at some
point there is a combinatorial
problem to and so we have limitation
and uh so this was a work we we've done
uh
with uh amin uh with norbert and uh with
emmanuel
and uh more recently uh jacob and jan
uh well let's say dynamic in processing
detection or
so the the our in our case what we want
to do is
recover all the kinetic constraints and
then
apply cdcm oh well apply uh
general resolution the what
jan and jacob have done is that they
integrated the detection
on the fly which means that they they
may not
have to recover everything to be able to
solve the problem
so those are two different approaches
so let's see how it works so there is a
a nice property actually if you think
about
what is a clause so this is what i
mentioned earlier
if you have a clause x1 or x2 or
xn actually what it means
it means that this is a not most n minus
one
constraints where all the literals are
negated
and if you think about this what we want
to achieve
is from that kind of
at most k constraints we want to be able
to
recover literals m1 to mp so that
you get a
more informative stronger
atmos constraints and if on to detect
m1 to np we are going to use unit
propagation
so we can show see that in one example
so
what we want to do we have a small
formula on the left
so those are only binary clauses and
what we want to do is to recover
x one plus x two plus x three uh less or
equal to one
so let's see how we we are going to do
this
so let's first consider the first clause
uh this is minus one or uh
not my so not x
one on the text two so this is actually
equivalent to x1 plus x2
less or equal to one and
so from from this we
what we want to achieve is to do to
perform unit propagation
and to be able to uh see what happens if
we propagate
uh x1 and what happens it will propagate
x2 so there's a small animation
uh so so here we have x plus one
uh x1 plus x2 less or equal to one now
uh next one we have the we try to
propagate
uh x1 so x1 propagate not text2
uh propagate not x4 uh not x4 propagates
in the text three
and we are done uh so we
we the the unit propagation of x1
propagates
x1 and the texture net x3 not x4 so we
do the same thing for
x2 and so with x2 we're going to
propagate not x1
x2 will propagate not x5 not x5 will
propagate not x3
so what we will get if we take the
intersection of
x1 and x2 we will have not x3
so it means that we can add in our
constraints x 1 plus x 2 we can add
x 3 to our uh at most
one constraint and uh that will
uh allow you to allow us to uh to
retrieve at any constraint of size
three instead of uh two and uh actually
we can try to propagate uh what happens
so and this process will terminate
because
if i try to propagate e2 and x2 and x3
uh there will be no more intersection
and the
the processor stops and so
this is um so the on the next side we
have
the algorithm and we will see that
the idea is simple so you pick any
clause that you so a clause of like
k plus one will gives you um
a candidate constraints at most k
and from that you try to
recover literals that will
allow you to increase the size of your
atmosphere
constraints so the the main issue here
so it's not a big deal if k is one okay
but uh when k is increasing you will
have to
compute all subsets of your literals
uh of size k and that that is
actually the the issue with the approach
uh because you
you have to to generate them uh do the
unit propagation and
compute the intersection uh and then you
you can do this
until the uh the intersection is empty
so we can see some examples of the
experiment so
in that case we so amin had a
syntactic detection
for atmosphere in mingling
and then uh norbert has the
implementation of both
syntactic recognition and the proposed
uni what we call it semantic one based
on unique propagation
and in that case we feed sat4j with a
general
light resolution on them and we compare
that with the cyto4j without
pre-processing and the sb sat has also
some detection of kinetic constraint
in that case and this is with a 900
seconds timeout so if you we look at the
table of results you will see that so we
have 14 instances
of this vision problems with uh six
different encodings
and so lingering uh finds uh and is
faster to uh to find the the pairwise
mind
because this is the syntactic detection
so risk with the syntactical
detection could also provide
to cite4j in a scientific trying to
solve some of the
sequential on product encodings and
almost the case for for pairwise uh
and then the um the approach with
the semantical uh encoding
uh allows to solve
many of the uh oncologists but not all
so um uh and therefore
uh sb sat as the the best result on the
on the lighter encoding faster and you
see that if you look at saturday without
any pre-processing i mean it's over one
or two benchmarks so this is really
ridiculous and so all the
so the time for set forget to solve
the the benchmarks should be uh
nothing because the it's really the the
time of the pre-processing
if you have all the the kinetic
contracts
so this is our on the the pigeon
principles we we have also
other examples of benchmarks
with many uh candidate constraints
so so those are called balance block
design and
those those were really in the set
competition
on the crafted category the very odd
benchmarks but actually that they are
just about counting so if you
retrieve the uh the kennedy constraints
they are just
very easy to solve and uh actually you
you see that
on all those cases um satrajin
was able to solve them either using
the syntactical or the semantical
recognition because those are only at
most two atmosphere constraints
and the last case is
the so-called uh challenging problem on
the next slide
um where we
so the the challenge benchmarks is a
from alan van gaal on iva swans was
um a case in which you
you have to it takes you you could run
a clasp at that time which was the the
best solver and crafted benchmarks you
can
run it during 44 hours it would not
solve it
but if you retrieve all the constraints
um
with sap4j
if you record very using the semantic
approach you will get at most three
constraints and you
you can solve it within a second and i
just did it uh
on my computer even with the pure java
approach
because you notice that the
implementation of the preprocessor was
done
um in c plus plus by by norbert
and just to check how many of the
constraints we could recover so
we took some surgical grids uh so you
you have typically many different
constraints because you have the rows
the columns
the cubes and typically
the approach takes
recover almost all the constraints
if you use the syntactic ones and the
semantic what it takes all of them
so this is sort of a very uh
well it works well because uh here we
have
a small cave so the issue being
that it's generic but we have
the issue that in practice it only works
if you have if you need to recover
um with a small king
and so if if he doesn't recognize the
encodings you will just get a bunch of
different
uh constraints with a few uh
with few literals i think i
am done homer
okay so maybe unless there are some
questions for daniel
i will continue with some open question
about pseudo boolean conflict analysis
yeah sounds good i think let's continue
okay so i i want i would like to present
two in interesting questions about
pseudobullion conflict analysis
so first the first question is about
improving the back jump level
at which the bank jump is performed
after the
conflict analysis
in sudo boolean solver so the idea
is to follow the classical set
approach and say okay when i found
once i found constraints that propagate
something
then i learned this constraint that i
propagate so as
i said earlier at the first
level i treat the constraint propagate
something
but actually this approach which is the
equivalent to the which is the first uip
uh
approach used in set solvers is not
always optimal in pb solvers
so let's consider this example so it's
quite a hard example
because uh to see really what happens we
need to have a
quite big constraint so basically here
we have
two constraints and we want uh to uh
though so this first constraint here is
conflicting
and this constraint here has propagated
a decision level for this
three literals here
so we perform a conflict analysis and we
can't sell the two literal f and j out
by uh so uh by
adding these two constraints and we get
this constraint here
and actually this constraint is
assertive
sorry this constraint is assertive
and we can just stop here and
i think it's it propagates
b at decision level two if i don't say a
mistake
but the important fact here is that if
we continue
the conflict analysis here and we say ok
i can continue and i will
eliminate the some little so one of c
d or j depending on the order of the
propagations
and actually these three literals will
be uh cancelled out by the cancellation
rule
and we get this constraint here which
this time propagates b
at decision level one so we have
improved the background
level by continuing to perform conflict
analysis
so this shows that the first uip is not
optimal
here and intuitively the idea is that
in the case of clauses
the first uip is optimal because when
if we continue to perform resolutions we
will only add
decision levels and this will not change
the
bank jump level or if it's
sorry if we change it it can only become
deeper in the search tree
because the the literal with
the which has the decision level at
which to back jump
will remain in the in the close
but here this is not the case because of
the coefficients that may
uh so
the idea is that if we add new literals
it does not
mean it will decrease it will uh make
the
example level deeper because of the
coefficient maybe this will not have
enough impact
to make the
bank jump level uh less interesting
but the problem is that of course in
some cases
the bike jump level will become not
really well in general bank jump level
we do not know
in advance whether performing the
cancellation here will improve the back
jump level or
worsen it so it would be interesting
to know uh
when to stop actually so because the
algorithm i presented
earlier is not always optimal so we need
to find a way
to improve it and currently there is no
real solution and uh
because we need to know when to stop and
uh really uh
if it will if con in two cents
the first one is whether um
we will improve the background level and
whether we will not
break an any other invariants so for
instance if we back jump to i
and we uh no no no if we back them but
if we continue
the conflict analysis to i maybe we can
lose the assertion the concept will not
be assertive anymore and
it will never be possible so the to make
it assertive
again and this is something we tried at
some point we tried okay so if we
continue
but in some cases the as the constraint
is not assertive
anymore and it will not be conservative
again so
there is no possibility so i mean you
could always run the decision learning
scheme no
i guess in cdcl you should always be
able to just run the full decision
scheme all the way to the top
and worst case like you get a class that
is asserted so i don't see that you
would ever lose assertiveness
maybe we should take it offline yes
maybe uh
this was this was really a first uh
first tried
so uh we just tried to continue and at
some point the
the closing the constraint was not
assertive
so uh this is really an open question at
this point yeah
i think you can get it back but it's
it's like again it's worth
driving home the difference from cdcl
because like one of the nice things with
first uip learn constraints is that
you know provably that among all the
constraints that you will
ever see regardless of you know whether
you do recursive clause minimization
later or something
the first uip is the one that will cause
the
the longest back jump guaranteed 100
provably like for for pseudo boolean
solvers that's actually
false you can improve your back jump or
you can even like
you can even maybe derive contradiction
in one shot if you keep doing your
conflict analysis beyond the first uip
point yes and actually this is the case
for
pigeon principle formulae exactly
so this was actually the first example
we had
on this
okay and the second question is about
improving
conflict detection so yeah for instance
so there's a there's a good question
actually so uh yeah so
how do we how is back jump level
computed how do you compute the
background level
uh so first we need to know whether the
constraint is assertive so we just
try to see uh whether the constraint
propagates something
at the lowest decision level
um meaning uh without considering the
current one
just bit the one before and to compute
the background level
we will look at the different
decision levels at which
the uh there are falsified letter in the
constraints
and we check whether it propagates
something
so basically this is done with the slack
so which is a
the sum of the coefficients of
non-falsified intervals minus the degree
and if
at the at a given decision level
the the slack is lower than
a coefficient of a little in the
constraint
then the constraint propagates this
literal
so and uh because uh the constraint
may propagate it towards a different
decision level we need to check
uh whether we have this property
of the slack at each decision level
at least at the beginning with the idea
is to make check it at
the decision developing in the construct
but since we know
that propagations are only triggered by
falsified intervals
we can only check this for decision
level at which
there is a falsified literally in the
construct
does that answer the question
uh the follow-up question your
constraint might
propagate something at some higher level
but the propagated literal is not
relevant for the conflict would you take
this into account when back jumping
oh uh i'm not sure to see the
this uh well i think one thing that's a
weird thing that can happen is that you
can
actually propagate something to the same
value right but
you could propagate it earlier than
before if you propagate something
then the literal is relevant
[Music]
so
another good question in the chat but
let's do this one first
so what did you want to say daniel no i
mean
uh well i mean it depends so um
if the literal is propagated then it is
relevant
okay because it means
we if at some point we have to propagate
it it is relevant for the constraint
but i think yeah it's not uh it's not
relevant in terms of uh general
relevance it is
in the sense of uh for the conflict it
is useful for the conflict
i think it is the sense of the question
okay
but this also raises a question that i i
think it's worth driving home this point
that
another difference from cdcl which we
already said but if so let's say it
again so
you can actually get the
a situation where a constraint is
propagating at a number of different
levels
so you get a choice whether you want to
back jump you know a few levels or some
medium amount of levels
or you want to back jump very far
because the constraint is asserting at
several levels how would you choose
no you need to to do it at the first
level where it is accepted
you will that you will pick the like the
the
nearest to the conflict where it is
assertive
no do the the farthest away yeah so the
faster way
the first time it becomes a set if else
it breaks
your solar invariant at least the the
the classical cdcl invariant because you
break the cdcl environment but
actually rounding sat would not do this
it it will like it will just
it will do the shortest possible by jump
i think
um the route yes
yes yes oh no i like the closest to the
conflict
yeah uh
do you have assignment levels different
no i mean we have the same
uh so we are still in the
in the old-fashioned cdcl it means that
it says though the idea is because you
you
you learn a new clause one of the
invariant from
cdcl is that as soon as you have
something that can propagate it
uh you you propagate it so to be in the
in a state where you have to go back to
a state
as if your children confront was
would propagate if it was there for the
beginning so this is the reason why you
have to propagate it
from the highest to the root
so again i don't think we do this
actually so
i think what ormond is looking for is in
some sense correct that
it this is somewhat similar to the
situation with chronological
backtracking
i think in general at least the way
rounding stuff is is
coded up unless you know one of the
members of my group changed it since
last time i
understood how this works rounding set
will it it will be
in general possible that you have
something on the trail
that has a correct reason
but if you started from the top then it
would propagate at an earlier level
now but you don't know this because you
didn't back jump that far
that is the situation that you can have
at least in rounding something
yeah no but i i know i i mean it's
correct that if you do currently
call backtracking you have different
data structures and it will work
differently
except for the till publication and
for this you need to go back to the
first
to the first decision level the smallest
the closest to the root the first time
the the constraint propagates you you
have to go
at that level and provocate at that
level
okay and another yeah so another
question was from i'm looking for now
from paul
beam so that the combinations
uh these combinations during conflict
analysis
presumably have been chosen as syntactic
combinations of two constraints is there
a geometric way
to understand the highest level inferred
from a pair of conflicting constraints
i guess the highest level at which
something inferred from a pair of
constraints would be propagating is that
the way to read the question
paul
yes yeah well i mean
for for us it's really um driven by
by the environments of cdcl
it's just that you need to maintain the
fact that you are going to propagate
as soon as propagation is
detected and for this you need to go
back
to the the highest level
in which propagates
yeah maybe the the prime that if you
do it another way unless you use some uh
techniques from logical cdcl i mean it
will just break the solver
because the so the solver expects
that everything that has been propagated
at some point
has been done so if you do not maintain
that
it would just not work i i i think
everything would still work actually so
maybe we should take that offline stefan
yes one comment about this
um i think the thing is it's true that
you lose propagation guarantees on your
learned constraints
so it might be that your unconstrained
would have propagated something
however your existing consensus database
will never be violated with respect to
propagation which is
in contrast to doing non-controlled
backtracking where i think also original
constraints can be violated
and this is why it will kind of it will
still produce the right result because
all original constraints are always
propagated right
also some learned constraints for
mispropagations
yeah but well in some ways you do not
really want to do
to make any difference between learn
constraints on the
uh and original constraints right even
if you can remove some
constraints but um well
so i think one reason why this works is
getting a bit technical is like
so so what goes wrong when you do
chronological
backtracking in cdcl one thing weird
thing that can happen
is that you don't have you can like
crash through
a decision level because suddenly you
thought you had
um like you were looking for a first uip
but suddenly all literals at the last
decision levels are somehow gone and
this
is because your trail was out the water
okay and then so if you want to do
chronological backtracking you have to
extend
cdcl to deal with this but in
pseudo-boolean solving we have to deal
with this
anyway because even if your trail is
perfectly kosher and in order
it can still happen that you get
cancellations
so that suddenly you have nothing at the
last decision level
yeah and then you're like you're looking
at it on the conflict side and like you
lost your
first uip constraint what should i do
well the answer is just go
continue to the next level so in some
sense like the extra code you need
to deal with chronological backtracking
since in cdcl
you already have it there in sudo
booleans homing because you're you need
to deal with that case anyway that's
sort of how i
view it regarding whether you could
somehow get to
the highest uh back jump level by some
geometric idea i mean something i guess
it's like the
it's the in some sense i guess it's the
least number it's the smallest
partial assignment for which the lp
the linear program is still infeasible
in some sense so i guess you could like
maybe talk to an lp solver and get
something
the question is like the lp solver will
take a long time to get back to you with
the answer
but definitely there's like you you
could think about in is
this is a general question like given a
trail and given a conflict
could you do something more intelligent
than this
like trivial cutting planes derivation
that we have
i think that's a great question that is
somehow hidden
inside paul beam's question as i read it
okay sorry for entropy
okay so the the next question i would
like to present
is about conflict detection in general
so here we have a set of constraints
that has a current partition assignment
and we have actually two conflicts that
occur simultaneously
so k2 is conflicting and q4 is also
conflicting
so at some point the server has to
choose one conflict
on which to um to perform the analysis
and actually we can so if we use
q4 we get this constraint here
but something which is quite uh
weird is that if we instead
well i need to check some okay no here
there is something which is quite real
because actually
here so at this step
we want to perform a consolation
between this constraint which is derived
with q4 and k3 and
um and
so we want to uh cancel out the literal
uh
nut d and actually the reason for not d
is uh ketu
and uh which is uh quite strange is that
kitu is also conflicting so
this is also a broken invalid from a
cdcl which is that we have conflictual
reasons
and this is because actually
we know that a constraint may propagate
a little
and then still become conflicting
and this depending on the order of the
propagation
we can just have conflictual reasons
so there is a way to not have
conflictualism here which is
actually to choose k2 as a conflict but
we need
somehow to know that we need to choose
k2
so here's a quite two question in one
which is uh sorry
we how to choose the conflict uh in this
case
and if we have a conflictual reason
what do we do with this uh with this
conflictual reason
there are two uh
first id that may come which are we just
continue the cancellation as if the
reason was not conflictual
or we can just say okay
i have a conflictual reason so maybe i
just stop analyzing
the the conflict i add and i use this
conflict instead
and there are probably other
other possibilities that we i we don't
think about for the moment
but still we we need to know that
this may happen and actually in this
case
well the two constraints we had so this
one here
and this form are not comparable so
there is
no clear uh best way to choose a
conflict
but unintuitively it's as if
if we have a conflictual reason it's as
if we did not
choose the we did not select the
earliest conflict in some sense
so this is really a it's an
open question once again on this point
that i wanted to to present here
and to the last part of
this presentation i would like to
discuss about the normalized forms that
i presented at the very beginning of
this talk
which has this form so here we we choose
to
have normalized form with a
at least operator
and so the first question is why do we
need a normalized form
so basically we need to have normalized
form because
when we apply the constellation rule we
need to have literals on the same side
of the relational operator so this is
intuitively what
why we need to have the same
relational operator on all constraints
to us to
be able to linearly combine the
constraints
but this does not prevent us from using
an at most operator so why do we not use
it
typically this is because if we want to
represent clauses
it's quite easy we just need to have uh
at least one constraint
so if we have clauses that are
represented natively we can use
many of the data structures that that
design
for cnn formula in set solvers such as
for instance
the watch literal scheme
and if instead we use the
the atmos operator then we can also have
a two-watt scheme but this time
instead of uh
updating watch literals when literals
get falsified we need to update them
when they get satisfied
so this kind of change the
house algorithm work at this at this
level in the solver
but the problem with the at-least
operator
is that it is not always practical to
have this
this representation for instance if we
consider a
optimization problem so
an optimization problem you have an
objective function and we want to
minimize
weighted sum of intervals under the
constraint of the problem
so let's so the optimization
algorithm works as follows in the
in pv solvers so
first we run the solver and it will find
a model which assigns a certain value to
the literals of the objective function
and so there is a value for this
objective function that is computed
based on this model
and to improve this model we just say ok
now i want to have an objective function
that has
a smaller value so we just add
this constraint to the solver
and okay to say we want to minimize
and if we normalize it so here it should
be a
an at least here so we need to uh
compute the sum of all coefficients here
but uh if we do so and if the
coefficients
are
quite big then the degree of the
constant will be
also big
even if the value of the objective
function is small
since here we the sum may be very big
so here uh the problem is that
as we use the saturation rule to have an
upper bound
of the coefficient then if the degree is
very big
in some sense the saturation wall will
be less
appliable so that we cannot decrease uh
much the size of the coefficients when
constraints
are combined so
this may lead the coefficients to grow
during the
constellation step used in
applied during conflict analysis so
maybe it would be interesting to keep
the natural
atmosphere presentation in at least in
this case
to represent the constraints
but the problem is that as i said we
have the saturation wall
but it is not applicable to a
at most constraints so we need to find
another rule
to replace it in solvers and actually
there is a
rule that is used as pre-processing in
mixed integer programming solvers which
is this one
which can be used instead of the
saturation rule
when we have at most constraints and
here we we need so in this rule we
need to update both the coefficient
of
the literal and the degree which is a
by a values which is computed based on
the
coefficients of the other literals so it
may be
a other
to understand and uh maybe to compute uh
than saturation but we with this four we
can
replace the saturation rule and deal
with uh
atmosphere constants
so if i recap briefly what i said on
normalized constraints
so we need normal less constraint to
apply the cancellation rule
so we need to have to choose either to
use
at most or at least as a relational
operator
the at-least operator is useful to
represent clauses
but sometimes we would prefer to use an
at most
operator for instance an optimization
problem
and we need to adapt again the proof
system if
instead of using at least a constraint
we use atmos constraint for instance
using the
the rule i presented in the slide before
and ideally
it would be interesting to have a way to
represent
both normalized forms
with atmos and at least and to apply the
operation
on which on the representation that
seems better
as this is done for instance for certain
codings of
pseudobullion constraints
so now i will conclude so
first a brief recap of what i presented
in this talk
so um current implementation of cutting
plants proof system in pv solver
are not fully satisfactory as we cannot
exploit
in pb sol electro in current previous
solver it's full strength so for
instance
uh we need if we want to derive a
cardinality constraint we need to add
additional steps
that are not taken into account during
the conflict analysis or
at some other points to and
to derive uh pb constraints in general
from uh
clauses and also we i
presented that it will eventually may be
introduced during conflict analysis
when combining uh
constraints and this little irrelevant
literal way then become artificially
relevant
may lead to the influence of weaker
constraints
and two as a counter-measure we can
apply the weakening rule and finish
actively literals
but this is a really aggressive
countermeasure that only derives for
this so
we need we it would be interesting to
have something
less aggressive and the best weakening
strategy that
we have in sight for today currently is
the application of the partial weakening
rule followed by a division step
and also i presented a complementary
heuristic implemented in cdclpb solvers
which are which can be
better adapted from the set uh
definitions
to uh better take into account the
properties of pb constraints and to
improve the performance
in the in saturday at least in this talk
as perspectives uh it would be
interesting to find other strategies
uh for applying uh critical planes uh
rule
to exploit more power so for instance
the addition rule that may be that may
allow to uh
derive general pb constraints from
clauses and
also we may uh design new strategies to
prevent the production of irrelevantly
tables
instead of removing them and using
that may be less aggressive that than
the weakening of ineffective literals
and we can combine the weakening
strategies and also
the different cdc strategies i presented
to exploit their complementarity and
to better study their interactions for
instance
using uh automatic configuration
algorithm
and uh so here i presented mostly uh
the
the impact of the new strategies
insight4j j unknown decision problem so
it would be interesting to you to
implement the new strategies in other
solvers such as running set for instance
and to study the impact on optimization
problems or other problems in general
that
decision problems and as
uh also it would be interesting to find
answer to uh
the open questions i presented such as
how to improve the detection of the
optimal background level during conflict
analysis
and how to deal with conflictual reason
and that may be encountered during
conflict analysis
so thanks for your attention and i will
take any questions that you may have
thanks a lot roma and thanks daniel so
i'm
on behalf of everybody i'm giving you a
round of applause
um a true deep dive into the inner
workings of pseudo-boolean solving we
had a lot of questions throughout the
talk
and it's already fairly late here in
europe
so we should let you off the hook fairly
soon i guess but are there some final
questions from the audience
so i i i'll uh uh ask one
so you you you mentioned in one line so
when you were discussing the general
uh this this is a great talk by the way
the but you
we you were mentioning one line you just
other ways of applying uh cutting planes
so so far
there's the round to one and then
there's the the forms the
of uh generalized resolution are there
any other
versions of cutting planes that are
more uh general that have actually been
applied
or uh yeah so that's
successful so uh
implemented in current pv solvers
they're all
only as a version based on generalized
resolution
all the implementation of running site
with the division and the one to one
and uh the really the
main lag in this uh in pb solvers is a
fact that they do not implement the
addition rule
that allow to combine any uh
kind of uh constraint without having to
having clashing literals to cancel out
and this is really because this little
this is how
the cdc architecture works we perform
consolations uh along the trail
and the the main perspective i think
is to try to find a way to implement a
general edition rule in solvers
thanks
so just to follow up on this question
just like also
when you about other cutting plane
systems so what about um
what do they do in integer programming
for example
are those techniques applicable here
and not really uh familiar with uh
programming solvers yeah so this is what
i was
curious about i just i know that they
apply lots of cutting planes during
their algorithm but i don't know exactly
the details i was just hoping if there's
some
discussion on that but okay
so i could so so the the point is that
you don't have
that you will they they do have lots of
cutting planes but they do it during the
search phase
uh they don't have this kind of so what
they totally
don't have is uh this conflict analysis
based on linear constraints that sudo
boolean solvers have
this seems to be entirely lacking they
do have
a conflict analysis but to the best of
my understanding
after talking to people who actually
know
how map solvers work and implement them
they the way mips solvers do conflict
analysis is that they
extract clausal reasons for everything
and then they basically run cdcl
which which is much much weaker than
what roman described
but then on the other hand what what
they will do on
during the search phase they will you
know they will solve lp relaxations and
then
repeatedly add cutting planes and
resolve the lp relaxations and this
is something that pseudo boolean solvers
have traditionally not been doing at all
yes i think they do the lp and then they
try to make a cutting plane that
improves their lp but this is not
applicable
like in the cdcl setting i suppose
um so i mean we have a
paper that does this self advertising a
paper that is
constrained meant for like in the
conflict analysis
specifically and the conflict analysis
well conflict is doing cutting planes
right i mean
what we're discussing saturation and
division are both cutting planes
so in that sense it is you know it is
some kind of
it is already applying cutting planes
rules but it's doing it
differently yeah
okay okay thanks yeah and i think that
the main issue we have currently is uh
that we produce those
irrelevant literals and this is really
so we need to find a way to prevent
uh producing those uh irrelevant
networks
and um and so maybe the rules are good
but just
the way we are applying them
there may be some cases where we should
not or we should uh
we can before they are
we probably need to find a new
new settings or new new constraints
before you rule well to adapt the rules
maybe to apply them
in the series
i mean somewhat related also to this is
that you could certainly envision
this was not quite what i think you were
asking about the mirror but
you could take the rich library of
different
cut rules that exist in mixed integer
linear programming and you could say
well what if i don't want to use
saturation or division or i want to use
some other cut rule
yes this you could totally do
uh to the best of my knowledge well
unless there are exciting
news from lon's forthcoming i don't
think this has been done
okay and just so it's it's certainly
conceivable to do it
okay it would be interesting to do it
and just a follow-up question so this is
maybe beyond the scope of the talk
itself but just a
if somebody could comment so if you want
to do this kind of cdcl for integer
um so here we're doing so the boolean
but if you have like an integer
constraint or a linear
constraint is there a way that one can
do the cdcl style with integer
constraints
with linear integer constraints
[Music]
i don't think it's it's not the
competitors for the mips thing but also
not competitive for the
for the pseudo boolean but like there
are people in the
kate community have been working on this
so newman who is
and consenting
so yeah there's a paper by the the
so this is but it somehow doesn't seem
to fly
it doesn't seem to work in practice
three groups which have exactly tried
that yeah
there's also this inset approach which
tries to just kind of resolve
a linear inequalities and hopes that it
gets a conflict but it's not guaranteed
to actually get it
and but it seems like as that means said
these things never seem to be as
competitive
as other techniques for them
okay i was just wondering if there are
any other comments
well i have one comment but i couldn't
find the paper i thought it was by luck
tag buzz by the
uh colleague where he had like a way of
reducing the the back jump level
even in cdcl by kind of doing
a cyclic resolution and you allowed it
in one particular case
and the surprising fact there was that
this never worked also lactose
figure that out so it's completely clear
sort of like at least in that context
like going for the best
back jump level was not good so they
have a paper on this but they only have
negative results and i also had this
and it was completely unclear to me why
if i reducing the conflict level is
counter-productive
anyhow so i couldn't find the papers i
look maybe somebody has
do you recall it danielle or i don't
know yeah but i think that this is a
paper in 2008 no
or something yeah some yeah but i i
couldn't find it so it's a pretty old
one yes
uh i i think it's a paper at
uh uh ikta you know
i think it's time light or something
like this
but yes it's like darjeel and say
i think
okay any other comments or questions
before i think
i mean i think we deserve the right to
call this a day but just to give a final
opportunity to people
so then i think let's just thank you
again for uh
an amazing seminar thank you so much and
for for
i think it's you know my take on this
some will obviously buy it but this
shows that there are so many good
questions that could be discussed either
immediately now after the talk on on
gather town or
you know in some other venue
at the simon so thank you thank you
again so much for the seminar
[Music]
all
bye